hello I'm Gavin and this is going to
work with my advisor Russell first and
let me introduce the well-known
orthogonal vectors problem we are given
a set of unfolding vectors of the
emergency and usually we consider the
American T is between logarithmic of and
unto the little of one and we want to
decide whether there exists vector U and
V such that their third product is 0 and
when this logarithmic of their simple
algorithm that runs in n square times
slogan and best algorithm bye-bye put
Williams and events in this amount of
time and the orthogonal vectors
conjecture says this problem with still
across logarithmic of the first time
unto the two- little of my of what that
means this problem cannot be solved in
sub quadratic time and this conjecture
is implied by strong eth here is the
graph of the reductions from the MP
complete word we have case in f that
problem and in the polynomial time warm
you have orthogonal vectors and here is
a here is a reduction from and the
casing access to always saying that if
the latter has a sub quadratic time
algorithm then Kasyanov set can be
solved the faster than 2 to the M and
there are a lot of reductions reducing
and for more solvent vectors to into
these problems including a distance LCS
for her distance sparse graph diameter
local alignment and longest common
substring our motivation is that the
casing offset is a complete problem in
in the mpu world and in
polynomial world we want to find us we
want to find a complete list of problems
so we showed that that there is a sparse
case of orthogonal vectors problem that
movie is a special case of this problem
and we can also show that on all these
three arrows and still hold true if we
replace orthogonal vector if we replace
parts orthogonal vectors here and we
also introduce a class of problems which
we call first-order graph properties and
it includes the problems like hitting
set click click and the K terminating
set and many other problems sports
orthogonal vectors is contained in this
class and we also show that this class
of problems are reduced to spar so V or
smart so V is complete in this class of
problems next we show was the first of
your problem means it is equivalent with
the two disjoint sets problem here we
give the input as a bipartite graph with
M edges and and on the left side artists
are the set and on the right side are
the elements if elements belong to a set
we create an edge between them and and
the input is the list of all the M edges
and output is to decide whether there
exists to the two sets that they are
disjoint here in here we consider as the
orthogonal vectors problem and to
disfranchise problems are equivalent if
we consider the orthogonal vectors of
problem in a smart way where we only
records the ones and don't post the
zeros in the input so so we say
orthogonal vectors is a special case of
two destroyers problem
the Parrot Heads of guava is very
unbalanced here the here's a website is
logarithmically small to the left side
and our question is to decide whether
the parasite graph satisfies this logic
formula where there exists set as one
exists at as to such that for all the
elements we have either when the element
is not contained in as one or is not
contained in as two similarly in we have
a sports cast of orthogonal vectors
conjecture where we replaced the time
and we replace the parameter and with
the parameter m next let me introduce
the first watercraft property by craft
we mean a bunch of binary relations plus
a bunch of urinary relations and we have
a fixed first order formula 5 with
cripples one quantifiers the quantifiers
are either there exists or for all the
input is a graph tree with n vertices
and edges notice that the input size is
the is M and we say the model checking
problem for formula Phi is to decide
whether G satisfies five here are some
examples the hidden side problem is to
decide whether there exists hitting CH
such that for all other set as their
existing elements and that is a common
element in the heating set and reset and
in the click click problem we want to
decide and if there exists k vertices
such as there is a pair of edge between
there is an edge between all pairs of
vertices and the K terminating set is to
decide whether there exists k vertices
suggest for all other vertices they're
very
at least and I drew from the dominating
set vertex to this vertex and the K
orthogonal vectors problem is to just
decide if there exists K vectors such
that for all indices at least for some
vector there isn't zero on this vertex
and on this index
by a simple recursive algorithm we can
show this the model checking for k plus
1 quantifier formula is so about in time
until the K minus 1 times m and we
conjecture it to request time I'm to
decay and this conjecture is implied by
strong age and the orthogonal vectors
conjecture and we can call it model
checking conjecture so we solve loss of
generality we can assume that the number
of input size the input size will reduce
the number of edges is near linear to
the number of nodes because otherwise we
can just use the simple an algorithm
above so we can we can always assume the
graph is sparse in this case and for the
dense graphs when Williams show that it
is decidable in time until the K minus 2
plus Omega where Omega is the matrix
multiplication exponent and when k is
greater than or equal to 9 it is
decidable in time unto the K and under
strong eth it requires time on to the
case of this bound is test where case at
least nine our main result is is we show
that the two or so the two disjoint sets
problem is hard for model hiking and
crafts under randomized reductions or we
can say the model checking conjecture is
just another name for sports orthogonal
vectors conjecture and our theorem
states that if two distances has the sub
quadratic time algorithms then the model
checking for k plus 1 qualifier formula
can be solved in time less than I'm to
the K and to prove this result we use
fine green reductions we say for problem
hi one with time t1 it is fine green
irreducible to problem hai to waste time
two if the reduction can preserve the
fine grain time complexity of problems
or we can say if ty 2 can be solved
substantially faster than t2 then PI 1
can be a source of substantially faster
than t1 we can show that for 4k plus 125
problems there is a penguin introduction
to okay 25 problems this can be done by
exhaustive search over the first
qualified variable so from to confirm
the k plus 1 quantifier problem we can
we can reduce it down to three qualifier
problems and we just need to show me the
three qualifier problems are reducible
to two disjoint sets and our steering
one says two teaspoons that is hard in
three qualified problems under
randomized fine groaning reductions
Steven Ruben is implied by theorem 2 and
0 mystery theorem 2 says there's a
reduction form for all exist for all
problems to exist exist for all problems
and the theorems recess there is a
reduction from exists exists for all
problems to two distances problem so
also possible quantifier structure our
list as are listed as follows for all
uses for all and its negation exists for
all exists by serum to can be reduced to
exist exist for all and education for
all for all exists and family rooms
three and they are reducible to two
different stats on the other hand and
this for qualified instructors are
considered as easy problems where we can
have algorithms running in time I'm to
the three halves
here are some examples of these
quantifier structures accreting set and
the Quaffle radius 2 is the first class
and the graph diameter to is the second
class and the three click and the three
independent sets are considered to be
the easy problems well the theorem 2 is
inspired by the respective is also
stated in the last talked in the
previous talk mmm that hitting set is
reducible to orthogonal vectors in the
tensile structure and we can generalize
this result to a sparse graphs and we
can show that the formulas and
quantified by for all exist for all
camping videos to exist exist for all
next we mainly show the proof of theorem
mystery we prove a theorem 3 when from
this following lemma these three
problems are equivalent under randomized
fine green reductions the first is to
destroy nests the second is set
containment and third is to set covering
and noticing this randomized the
reduction is only randomized reduction
other parts of our proof are always
deterministic here's the definitions of
the three problems which we call the
basic problem the first is to this one
says we have seen before and it is
represented by this logic formula and
this bipartite graph and the second
problem is set containment it is to
decide if there exists to stats as one
and as to such that as one is contained
in as to it can be represented by this
logic formula and we're free for all
elements if it's in as one and done is
in us too and we can we can represent
the implication
relation using the negation of you is in
as one or using us to and it can be
represented by this paragraph and to
start cover is similar East assess
whether there exists to assess which
covers the whole universe and it can be
represented by this large formula we can
observe that the first problem has to
negations and this problem has only one
negation and this problem has no
negations and this means if we could
find a way to complement all the sets
whereas to is the chosen form then we
can reduce from the first problem to the
second problem where we can can replace
the purple edges with the blue edges
then it becomes a set containment
instance similarly if we could
complement all the cells where s 1 and s
2 are chosen from then the two disjoint
sets are reducible to a to set cover
problem however we are not able to in
complement the set directly because we
are working on a sparse graph where the
number of edges is almost linear in the
number of nodes so to preserve the
sparsity of the input graph we have to
think about and other reductions our
reduction technique is to use universe
shrinking self reductions on the basic
problems for four basic problem problem
one we can use a randomized self
reduction to the same problem with a
smaller universe new prime and the
sucess as one and as to our map to two
sets as one Prime and s 2 prime then we
can complement the stairs on a small
University you so it becomes as one
prime and as the as 2 prime bar so we
can show complementing on this small
universe the country
the fun growing the complicity on the
sparse graphs here is the example of
reducing from set set containment to two
different states because the graph is
sparse there aren't too many large
degree vertices so for the large degree
vertices there are not many of them we
can do exhaustive search on them and see
if they are in the solutions and then we
remove them from the graph so the graph
has only small degree vertices then we
can stop reduced in this graph to a
smaller universe u prime and we can
complement other sites on the new Prime
and we can show because the degree is
small the error probability is small to
do the universe drinking we use a bloom
filter that randomized that randomly
maps each element of you to t elements
in you frame uniformly at random so last
hp's imprisonment Matthew function and
the funny for each test which is a
subset of you we can define a such as
form which is a subset of U prime for
the set containment problem we can see
if if as one is contained in as two then
at one prime is always contained in as
two prime but if as one is not contained
in as two and and all the elements of s
1 are unfortunately mapped into elements
inside as to frame then an error occurs
we show that the yes instance is always
knife to the yes instances and no
instances with high probability math to
no instances and the waste small
probability math too yes instances in
particular we show that when the size of
s 2 is small then the probability of pot
of false positive is exponentially small
the last step of this reduction is from
the general for from the general exists
exists for all problems to the basic
problems we define the hybrid problem
which connects the two problems in the
middle the hybrid problem is a
combination of basic problems where the
universe is partitioned to for
destroying the universes and we are
looking for a solution s1 and s2 net
simultaneous need satisfy the four
conditions the first is that on universe
you 0 they are destroying stats on
universe you one as one is contained in
s2 universe youtube as one contains as 2
and on universe you story as one and as
to work covers the universe usually we
show that we can construct an instance
of the hybrid problem of linear size in
linear time family is the conclusion we
we have we have Ruben approved the
relations showed in this graph and in
evil and if one day someone prove that
strong eth is false then the sparse
orthogonal vectors conjecture my still
hold true then we in the polynomial word
we can still have this relation finally
is open problems the first open problem
is to find a complete problem in the k
plus 1 qualifier problems we can we can
find a complete problems worse than
specific quantifier structures for
example k orthogonal vectors is complete
for in problems with que existe no
quantifier and one universal quantifier
but we don't know if this problem is
completed for general k plus 1
quantifier problems the second oven
problem is to find similar
results for dense graphs but dense
graphs are different from the sparse
graphs in the sense that if we magnify
the number of edges we can go through
all the k plus 1 variables using time
I'm to the K so we can save one variable
here but if we measure the number of
vertices intense graphs we won't have
such advantages so the design of
algorithms will be changed and the third
open problem is to extend this result to
the model checking in hierarchy
structures which we mean from web
properties to hyper graph properties the
last open problem is to find the
complete results for dynamic programming
problems the motivation is that we want
to clean up more messy in the reduction
graph so we found many strong eth hard
problems have dynamic programming
algorithms and many of them cannot do
batters and dynamic programming and we
want to know what what properties do
these problems they have in common and
we want to know if there is a complete
problem in this kind of problems
questions
versus Parsons it got much better person
yeah well in in internal turns case they
you already use the algorithms based on
matrix multiplication and in the sparse
graph most algorithms are not based on
it and in an hour example we we heavily
depend on because the graph is sparse
there are not many large degree vertices
and for some was and and forth and for
the large degree versus you can do
exhaustive search and the first multiple
we have some properties
so let's